no one is safe on the show right no not
even you no murder-mystery meets a
reality show on YouTube Red's a new
series escape the night with joy
Persephone and only ET was on the set is
insane you may be digging up dead bodies
you may get stabbed it's really
interesting you can expect a lot of body
parts explosions a lot of suspense and
I'm telling you it's not scripted so we
don't know what's going on there's gonna
be a lot of scares you're gonna see your
favorite youtubers getting so scared and
peeing their pants and just seeing
really crazy fun reactions from I kind
of want to choke you because we are
going through some serious things I
might have thrown one of my good friends
under the bus so it's kind of
unfortunate you let my friend die
Justine maybe she needed to go honestly
what is she even doing here I got a
complete this bad luck so it turns you
into a monster believe you look nice I'm
super excited for you guys to watch it
I'm excited to watch the how everything
goes